Avatar Singh and his neighbors are still
in shock at what happened here last week
they saw monkeys being shot just a few
meters from their apartments
in this video after can be heard
questioning one of the men who said he's
from Malaysia's wildlife and national
parks department during the
confrontation another man throws what
appeared to be several dead monkeys into
the back of a pickup truck the man with
the rifle is also when the monkeys sat
down on a branch there he just shoot
down the monkey fall
and I know from where one fellow went in
took the monkey out by the tail with a
Barbie the baby is still cling to the
body come and throw in the trunk other
CSA they saw some monkeys being shot at
close range after they had been trapped
in a cage
the state wildlife department denied
those allegations and said there were no
elements of Cruelty in its operation
we found this on the ground it appears
to be a 12 gauge shotgun shell a website
that sells hunting equipment describes
these shells as Top Notch for large
birds and smaller gain
state wildlife department said it had
acted on complaints about damage to
property and threats to people's safety
some of the people who live here say
they've co-existed peacefully with the
monkeys for years and are disturbed by
what they consider an inhumane approach
to dealing with them
it was heartbreaking to watch it's a sin
to kill I told them not to hurt the
monkeys but they wouldn't listen
lawyers say long-tailed macaques should
not be killed because they are protected
by law
the wildlife department cannot kill any
animals in the event that an animal has
become a nuisance or is a disturbance
then the solution is very simple The
Wildlife Department is supposed to
capture the said animal or animals and
relocate them not kill them this is not
the first time the wildlife department
has been accused of acting illegally two
years ago Witnesses say at least 20
Dusky Leaf langers were shot dead by
wildlife department personnel on grounds
they had attacked humans even though the
species is listed as endangered under
International conservation law Florence
Louis Al Jazeera Kuala Lumpur